hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John Humphrey here guys one of
the fans favorite moments of the last
Jedi that every fan loved it recreated
in Lego 4vets
Huxley bird studios Thank You Huxley
Berg but stars let a Jedi throne room
scene and Lego
it's a self-explanatory funny idea to
recreate this go for me hey Lego Star
Wars movies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ray looks chubby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
turn the dial
I think I think someone recorded this in
the theaters and then
[Music]
[Laughter]
man well done well I think this guy did
a walking dead one of Glenn's deaf too
it's cool to see I definitely have no
clue at all and I feel like I couldn't
even learn how to put something like
this together the only thing I wish was
that Snoke was a little purple doubt not
purple I looked a little more like snow
but be hard to do with away go ahead
yeah you yeah I just made me think I
would love to see a Lego Star Wars movie
yeah cuz the Lego Star Wars games are
huge and why not it doesn't have to be
candid it doesn't have to be within the
Star Wars world I feel like our brothers
could be cool with the lego movie
franchise doing yeah it's Star Wars
madhab that we need F dizzy would be
cool with Warner Brothers in a weird way
this got me thinking about the tone of
Lego movies in general and I was sort of
compelled just by it being an actual
scene and then when they cut to the
later fight yeah like underwhelming the
action of that is actually created a new
kind of funny play I wouldn't mind
seeing a lego movie that isn't quite as
anally in-your-face I'm exploring Star
Wars you know universe through Lego
might be a nice way to ease the tension
as we're dealing with this new brand of
maybe if we had a Lego Star Wars movie
around to lovingly you know incorporate
things series but also I think that
could be great actually yeah man
that's just you know money waiting to
fill everybody's pockets
well done Huxley Berg Studios you should
subscribe to this guy only has 49
thousand subs he clearly deserves way
more we'll put a link to his channel in
the top comments so you guys can make
sure to subscribe to this dude please do
so the meantime you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell and you can follow us on patreon
it's like a second
YouTube channel over there are plenty of
different types of videos we do a lot of
discussions and when some reactions as
well schecky